oh this guy Konstantin Kyson I'm not
sure who he is
what is he's the he's a winner of Jewish
comedian of the year and coast of the
triggered pod centrist chad here's what
he writes I'm gonna read you this whole
thread it's very very important
he writes you're not you're going to
hate me for writing this you're going
you're going to resist what I say
because you don't want it to be true
you're going to pretend that I want this
to be true when in fact there's nothing
I hate more than the fact that this has
that that that this the fact that it has
come to this here's what happens next
if protesters continue to deface
monuments like Winston Churchill's
statue and burn British flags on the C
note f you will see groups forming to
defend them these groups will be
composed primarily of young angry white
men and led by people with links to
groups like the EDL and Tommy Robinson
this is already happening the groups
will gather in city centers to quote
defend our country they will have names
with words like patriotic British
defense in them inevitably they will
clash with the current protesters and
the police under pressure from the media
and political class the police will
overreact they will treat these groups
differently to the BLM protesters they
will use force they will detain people
for breaking lockdown rules they will
issue stiff sentences the media will do
the opposite of what they did with black
lives matter instead of talking about
how quote twenty-seven police officers
were injured in largely peaceful
protests they will run major front page
headlines like 27 police officers
injured by far-right violence at this
point the majority of the public will
lose the ability to be nuanced the
double standards will be too obvious to
ignore fueled by a constant stream of
images of white people kneeling washing
POC feet and publicly apologizing as
they already are they will conclude that
their very identity is under attack
at this point all this all their
sensible aversion to supporting thuggish
far-right groups will evaporate they
will believe they are in a war for their
survival and extreme measures are
justified at the next election which
will likely be brought forward for one
reason or another fuelled by mass
unemployment resulting from the economic
depression far-right parties will make
significant inroads when I say far-right
I am NOT talking about what the left
with the far left call far-right
just anyone who talks about controlling
immigration I'm talking about genuine
far-right parties that talk about
reversing immigration and deportations
these parties will not win seats or get
anywhere near government but they will
put a you camp like pressure on the
Conservatives Boris Johnson will likely
be ousted as too soft and liberal and
replaced by a law-and-order hardliner
from here I'm afraid the journey is all
too obvious the only way to prevent this
is to reverse the re racialization of
our society either we learn to live
together or the very idea of a
multi-ethnic society is over and I
completely agree and there's a another
article that talks about this that says
quote far-right groups are already
showing up in the UK to defend and to
fight back and you already have the
sentiment in the u.s. that you have
clearly one ideology that is favored by
the police Fort Worth New York and the
racetrack in North Carolina that claim
to be a protest got shut down yeah so
what does anyone gonna conclude in this
was an imminent imminent threat the
government did you hear about the Naval
Academy alumni or whatever who had his
his Facebook you know conversation
leaked or something mm-hmm so apparently
the story is this guy was sitting with
his wife and he somehow accidentally
started a live stream on his phone
through Facebook okay yeah and they
started talking about black lives matter
and he basically said exactly what this
dude said that white people can't speak
up anymore they're under attack they're
losing their jobs how does this make
sense then some racial slurs got dropped
he was forced to apologise but this is a
very important story because it shows
you that I mean this guy I didn't listen
to the conversation it didn't sound like
he was overtly racist but it did sound
like he was angry that he as a white man
was being attacked simply for being
white their memes about this where it's
like you got a bunch of people saying
something like you know you're white and
you're bad okay so then all the white
people band together and they go oh no
they're forming you know evil groups and
it's like you you threatened them you
insult them based on raced race so they
did exactly what anyone would expect
them to do they created a group based on
what we're but they were being attacked
over so I think I think I think things
like this are obvious I think it'll be I
think it's likely yeah
and then this is uh this is what I
warned about a couple years ago that I
don't think anti [ __ ] could ever really
win they're too pathetic they don't have
guns they're whiny and they crush under
the collapse under pressure yeah now
when they finally do see some few blocks
they're like please bring us vegan meat
substitutes as a sign of their privilege
in their and their expectation of what
they're owed yep
so here's what I think is a likely
potential for what we'll see you know
coming off of this statement from this
guy Constantine the far left and their
constant riding in their attacks are
creating a secret base of Trump voters
Trump and Republicans will win the left
will freak out they'll get even more
aggressive and regular people will say
please just to make it stop and and
Trump will by sending in the military
invoking the insurrection act yeah and
shutting it all down the people will beg
for the authoritarian police state and
they will get it and then you will have
this constant fear in people's minds
which will result in like what constant
was saying a bunch of far-right groups
are emerging then you end up with you
know I more more white and edit Aryan
politics and people just start reverting
to the rules of the past you know 40 or
50 years because they're scared yep and
that's the fall to the left it's
actually kind of worries me because I
think the far left pushes so hard to the
left because they only ever think that
they will win and I don't think they
recognize that their action is going to
cause a very strong opposite reaction
because it turns out that people don't
really like the far left all that much
they don't like being controlled they
don't like authoritarianism it's not
just that it's that you're right but
it's also what we're seeing from these
leftists goes against the grain so when
you have somebody who grew up in this
country and they're like a dude and
they're like I like playing football and
I like attractive women I like women
with big boobs and then they get told
they're wrong and - shut up and you're
toxic they get angry it's not even about
being white it's about being told that
everything you do is toxic all the time
and no matter what you do you're wrong
and you're bad and they get angry and
they hate it and they want to find
somebody who they can relate to right
what the left is trying to do is
essentially rewrite normal human biology
they're trying to claim that
they say there's there's you know
they've literally said biological sex
isn't real and they love playing this
game where they're like literally no one
believes that it's like dude what's the
guy's name Nicholas Matt yeah and the
debate with Jordan Peterson where he was
like basically it is not true that their
thing is biological sex and we can I'm a
story of him edit his stories in a story
enough medicine I can unpack that but
for the interest in the interest of time
I you know I won't they really do
believe it when JK Rowling came out and
said I respect and love all of my trans
friends yeah I will fight for you but I
have the live experience of a female and
believe that should be protected she got
attacked for it so you take a regular
person who knows nothing right mm-hmm
and put them in front of a fascist who
says you know family god tradition and
they're gonna be like I recognize these
things and they're gonna say maybe it's
cold out night I remember Christmas when
I was growing up you take the far left
for them to say you're not actually a
woman you're on men straighter learn
about what that it's so insulting yeah
and who do you think they're gonna pick
the crazy person smashing windows or the
dude who walks up with you know he's got
the haircut where the sides are shaved
and it's slicked over to the side and
he's wearing a suit and he says I just
want you to be happy I want you to have
faith in God and I want you to be a good
wife and we're gonna make sure you're
safe and there's gonna be a bunch of
goons with guns thing behind them saying
and we'll make sure you're safe they're
gonna pick it they'll pick it out of the
way because it's safety and security and
the people running through the streets
smashing windows and threatening people
and talking about there being no genders
or infinite genders freak people out
chaos that does I think a lot of stuff
we're seeing has a very good possibility
that results in fascism and I think you
know I wonder if that's how it happened
in Europe cuz in Germany and Spain and
other countries the Communists and the
fascists were fighting each other all
the time and the regular liberals got
attacked by them too and you kind of
stood back it did nothing and that's
kind of how the bad stuff happens so I
wonder if in the end when given the
choice between what they call progress
but is actually just a mishmash of weird
ideas and authoritarian traditionalism
people choose what's familiar and what
they think will be you know safe and
fine yeah think about it this way man
they ban Gone with the Wind
yeah but they also they also banned baby
it's cold outside
there's going to be a ton of people
we're in their 40s and 50s who are gonna
think back to that suburban life where
it was Christmastime and they woke up
early in the morning and there was mom
making a batch of chocolate chip cookies
and she turned on the song baby it's
called outside and then they remember
mom dancing with dad and having a good
time and they're gonna say that was home
that was family that was safe and now
they're being told you're wrong you're
evil you're racist some people fall for
it some people are gonna say that was
bad
now tradition is absolutely fine it's
the authoritarianism part where things
become evil progress is absolutely fine
it's the authoritarian part where things
become evil yeah so we have right now a
liberal society but the problem is I
think too many liberally minded people
Liberty minded people libertarian
classically classically liberal or
otherwise won't say anything the
Conservatives have been speaking up and
they get banned for it why because
liberals won't speak up I talked to my
friends about it and they're just like
oh I don't know I don't care I won't be
involved that's irresponsible okay then
when you lose your freedoms and you get
you know kicked in the butt and then all
this weird stuff arts weird stuff starts
happening now they're there apparently
in colleges a friend of mine is doing a
course they have a specific course where
you have to remove gendered language so
it's it's like what we saw with that UN
segment where you call your landlord
your owner yeah that's in college and
that's a part of their mandatory
curriculum yeah they're infiltrating the
colleges and changing curriculum for
their end yeah so that's not new I
actually had a friend who lost a
girlfriend she broke up with him because
she took a course on this kind of
language and gender changing stuff in
college and she's like you're part of
the patriarchy I'm sorry I can't be your
girlfriend anymore I've heard so many of
these stories on like on reddit yeah
people are just like you know my
girlfriend went to was some feminist
class and all sudden she's like I have
to break up with you because you're
you're the patriarchy made me so so mad
because it was my friend as a super nice
guy and I was like dude welcome to the
brave new world Oh
1984 everything mish-mashed a little bit
yeah but you got a little bit of the
Fahrenheit 451 we got a little bit of
brave new world and yeah hey Constantine
Kyson 'he's new special is called or
well that ends well
oh no interesting who is he I don't know
he's a comedian man he is based he just
oh really
two plus two equals four biological sex
is free
men and women are different so I
somebody retweeted this thread from him
and he says he's a centrist Chad and
yeah but a start was right I've been
saying this I've been thinking it and
it's it's it's what actual white
supremacists are hoping for I I'm not
I'm not trying to say that everybody on
the right is that's how I'm saying I'm
saying that the small tiny fraction are
crossing their fingers hoping that white
people are forced to be identitarian
they want it to happen yep they want it
and I think they're gonna make it happen
and you know why I don't you know you
know what I don't I don't like it I like
the idea of America being a melting pot
where you can all hang out together and
in our shared identity is that we're
Americans
oh yeah that's but they're erasing that
they're erasing it the left is erasing
you're not allowed to be American to be
think about if you're a proud American
then you're their enemy Don Lemon says
he wants everyone to see him as a black
man he doesn't want people to ignore
that and I'm like so you you want to
maintain a racial division yeah exactly
they run what do they want and do they
want equality or do they want to be
known as someone that's different
reference what did Terry say he he said
we can't get rid of white supremacy
without whites otherwise otherwise we
have black supremacy and they got man oh
man but he's right yep yeah it's not
equality we're all in this together
that's how we finish they don't you want
equality dude I know that's that's what
he how that he finished that tweet
though yeah it's like so you want black
supremacy then if that's the case they
don't you want I want equality I want
everyone to be treated equal right I
think I like that yeah yeah you can't
get it if people use identity as a
pretext because you won't you will never
have it you know what are we gonna do
are we gonna like we have to create a
quota we're 5 foot tall women have to be
in the NBA it's only fair all NBA teams
now must be completely diverse at least
one person must be under 5 feet that was
at least one person must be over 6 feet
you must have an Indian person you must
have an Asian person you must have a
white person a black person a Mexican
person the teams must one person must be
overweight one person must be under way
one person must have more muscle mass in
their arms we can go on yeah one person
must be the wheelchair oh yeah yeah
white person optional of course no no
you gotta have one what do ya we're
talking about real diversity oh where
you try and make the sports team likes
everything yeah that's what they're
gonna know but they don't even want that
though no they don't that's not even
what they're saying I think a lot of
these a lot of these people that we see
like high-profile black lives matter
people like Ice Cube for instance yeah
are probably followers of Farrakhan in
the Nation of Islam no so when when
Farrakhan got banned Snoop Dogg made an
Instagram video where he was flipping
out saying how dare you ban the minister
you know and then he ordered all of his
or he said he told all his fans post
videos of you know Minister Farrakhan
onto Instagram so they can't do this
yeah yeah that you have that clip from
Ice Ice Cube he posted anti-semitic art
okay that apparently shows a bunch of
Jews playing Monopoly with like black
people under the sofa and he got it he
got a text for it and then somebody I
think was Majid Nawaz posted a picture
of him with Farrakhan and they're like
what do you think these people are all
about yeah
like do you realize they like the
women's March people were seeing at his
event they called him the greatest of
all time they really do support this guy
in his in his ideas and he says a whole
bunch of crazy stuff so III question
when they prop these people up what they
really want mm-hmm well I just look at
who they follow and and and who they
think is the greatest of all time and
you'll get a better understanding I
don't say everybody believes that stuff
but thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you